[Musique]
qu'est ce que j'ai aujourd'hui je vais
analyser une séquence sans drame qui
s'est passé sur ce plateau c'est quoi un
drame et quelques jours est-ce qu'on en
parle tout à l'heure où s'ils se
passaient un drame et shopping
d'analyser cette séquence est terrible
drame un drame ce plateau ça vous
concerne vous et ça concerne une
personne qui est ici ça oui précisément
par là précisément un peu plus âgés que
la moyenne
il n'était pas là au bout un témoin j'ai
attendu la fin de l'année pour parler de
ce drame mais j'ai attendu ma peau neuve
alors écoutez le drame
on le saura dans instaure alors savait
que dès que j'ai fini ma chronique je
fonce regardé l'émission de but chez moi
comme christophe carrière qui regardent
aussi des missions de plus chez lui il
sera là tous les vendredis mais j'adore
clé même pas mal de poids il calme toi
c'est mon ami salut à toi ces mots là
mais je dois je suis bien mais qu'elle
n'a pas manqué ce cas c'est mon calme
toi tu fais et c'est pas fini
je suis obligé de revenir sur un nouveau
drame qui s'est produit si amiens
quelques jours cyril hanouna est un
surhomme animateurs journalistes
politiques dirigeants un club de foot ou
encore serveur dans un bar à chicha
on le sait pas forcément alors forcément
avec toute cette pression le risque de
craquer et c'est notre amie isabelle
morini bosc qui en a fait les frais à le
parler à tort et surtout à travers au
bout d'un moment le dieu du paf craque
c'est la banalise
car prononcé l'appel du 18 juin 1940 à
la rabobank sur les ondes de la bbc
razak a pas parlé j'ai levé le doigt
babel où pendant qu
[Applaudissements]
on banalise et les lynx ont des
chroniqueurs eric naulleau n'avait pas
été aussi choqué depuis la fois où eric
zemmour enfin un compliment une personne
maghrib il emprunte personnes maghrébine
valérie bénaïm qu'on pensait être une
femme bien elle se réjouir honteusement
de la vanne de série le me jean michel
maire lui c'est tout en sobriété
regarder
le comédien de théâtre et c'est de jouer
la stupéfaction qu'il y ait fabien vous
regardez ils sont figés comme s'ils
venaient de voir le fantôme de rachid
arhab la traumatisme géraldine max
éléments sont synchro regarde
or bernard et consorts d'isabelle en
leur promettant lui offert le dvd de ses
meilleures prestations sous le soleil
adhérez de 45 secondes et vous serrez
vous sentez mal pour isabey alors bien
sûr vous allez gagner at on trouvé les
mots les plus gentilles pour vous faire
pardonner
évidemment ça barracuda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on habite ensemble gilles tu le sais
partiellement vrai mais c'est vrai que
tu prends le voile après 55 ans thomas
singer on a vu une icône chanter dans
ballast en poste à vue une licorne
défoncer la race de cyril hanouna
c'est la différence entre tf1 et ses
mythes licorne frappent les kiwis
séverac tf1 s'est vite c'est pas là il
faudrait et donc il semble que l'icône
s'est fait pousser des ailes aux
chroniqueurs je pense ça les a un peu
chauffé
ils ont décidé de vous en mettre plein
la gueule aussi alors devant la justice
ces images prouveront série pour vous
que chaque jour dans cette émission il
ya eu un subordination on regarde le
backlash
[Applaudissements]
quand vous sur la plage passe quelque
chose qui m'intrigue vous disiez
toujours vous détestiez le sablais
contact dégagement à la pelle en
chaussettes ouais mais bon quoi yen qui
tombe bien ce jeudi va voir non mais je
joue à voilà vous pouvez quand même
touché le sable sur gautier pas de sable
[Applaudissements]
ici j'ai gagné ici
voilà la quête de nadal une playstation
4 un voyage en laponie
ouais un voyage en tunisie ouais un
prime ouais j'ai jamais rien vu deuxième
un escroc mythomane
comment vous surnomme dans le milieu est
mythomane et ça fait une grosse connerie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
part avec la mobylette électrique des
médias locaux la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'adore cotiser j'adore mais j'adore
donc être pas j'adore il continue ça va
vous êtes content subordination du tout
comme ça vous allez continuer oui il va
ce sera pire
oui elle va vous avez raison les
banquiers centraux car il attend ça
jean-michel heureusement se souvenant
alors il eu un problème nasale
c'est ça mon fils a eu il envoyait photo
de lui par éthique il un problème dans
le nid je pense qu'il a peur il sera
dans autour de moi parce que demain
c'est le prime donc y aura tout le monde
vient sera tous les chroniqueurs demain
même si vous n'avez pas vu depuis quinze
ans arrive vraiment oui on voulait
donner un cachet à tous il relève des
chroniqueurs mon panier jean-michel donc
on n'aura pas la chance de le voir sa yo
té mais surtout n'aura pas la chance de
le voir rater des vannes et profitèrent
sa tête qui changent d'émotion quand il
se rend compte que ça passe pas du tout
auprès de vous oui c'est mon préféré
franchement pour jean-michel il prend un
four c'est de l'art on est habitués donc
c'est le petit jean michel regardez bien
le passage du jury gola je rigole plus
du tout
[Musique]
voilà déjà près de dix ans que le petit
jean michel tentent chaque jour de faire
rire son professeur sur la vie de ma
mère
charest et bah tu peux plus le dynamo et
là il se barre quelques ratages 8e passe
à twitter non mais quand son camarade
castaldi imite un bruit de moteur
le petit jean michel montre une fois de
plus son sens unique de la répartie la
cible favorite du petit jean michel
c'est son ex la petite isabelle c'est
t-rex le t-rex
quand on parle de qui aura la fève dans
la galette des rois
il taquine une nouvelle fois la petite
isabelle isabelle chaque année quoique
et le khamsin donc
et le petit jean michel tantin dernière
fois de faire rire son professeur en se
moquant de l'âge de qui la petite
isabelle bien sûr vous quelles qualités
motreff quand vous étiez vous des
lettres quoi moi me marier pour pouvoir
écrire et dessiner sans bosser ça a
marché deux ans
d'accord construire une cathédrale de
tout ça
[Musique]
il sera de retour demain alors il est
temps de récompenser les gens donc avec
2010 se termine donc je vous récompenser
les meilleurs éléments de l'émission ah
oui j'ai essayé de remettre l'award du
meilleur imitateur pour le général dans
2.0 les nommés sont matthieu delormeau
pour un patchwork et d'imitations aidé
par cyril hanouna aznavour qui fait un
petit duo avec johnny johnny qui arrive
à manquer qui donne son avis sur roanne
n'a pas les mots je dis que c'est il me
plaît meilleur chanter avec nous cette
heure-là céline bas sur le tibet
inchangé jean michel maire pour son
imitation impressionnante de patrick
bruel
je sais faire que bruel à l'aîné ouais
ben eager
et isabelle morini-bosc plus connu sous
le nom de la chatte en chaleur
[Musique]
[Rires]
non
c'est bizarre mais ça tu aimes les
imitateurs vent en poupe c'est bon quand
même quoi mathieu c'est mathieu est très
fort ça finit très fort mais là il faut
être entre le ridicule
jean-michel le problème c'est que c'est
beaucoup trop loin serviès mathieu
limite c'est beaucoup et c'est bien je
suis fort pourquoi entre autres isabelle
laon cela on reconnaît la patte tpmc
voulait refaire et on tue la grosse tête
pas payés pour donner des infos médias
à
[Musique]
ça ne me choque dans la gorge qui
manifestement ne le sait pas il passe
son temps ce moment à monter sur l'autre
l'immersion vous êtes mieux dans le
visuel
parmi les 2 pour découvrir celui ou
celle qui aura été officiellement élu
tard baba 2019
c'est thierry baumann qui est en train
de compter les votes du public outre
affaires global c'est le sait le garçon
qui fait miss france qui est très sympa
et qui travaille en soir par an non non
il fait la pub pour le chocolat si oui
les chocolatiers l'année à une fois par
an c'est effectivement alors ouais c'est
vrai c'est vraiment ans aujourd'hui sans
le connaître le 23e tabac de thé pmp
celui qui a le plus tacler ses collègues
musique de suspense
un plan que cyril hanouna remporté le
trophée seulement 22 fois sur 22 et sert
il pas mieux
qu'est ce qu'on sait de cette
performance quand même qui est
exceptionnel dans tous les cas comme
dirait laurent paganelli
franchement quand je vois tout se prend
dans la gueule vous savez quand on crée
et se détendre un match qu'on voulait on
a bien raison c'est vrai comme est
castaldi qui m'attaquent oui c'est là
que jamais s'est attaqué à jamais eh
bien on va savoir tout de suite sinon je
trouve que arrivée celle de noël font ça
faisait un peu calmée dans ses oreilles
les faits nous y arrivons donc c'est
pour ça je vais annoncer tout de suite
pas perdre de temps le 23e tard baba et
[Applaudissements]
de l'année jeudi et signalé
est-ce que vous voulez voir pourquoi
vous avez été lus 21 je ne comprends pas
pourquoi
très bien robert si vos parents mais
vous avez une présence ah oui car vous
allez avoir une absence de fabien
lecoeuvre
non les chéris un doigt d'honneur
un doigt d'honneur tirer le geste
préféré de série des nouba
non pas du tout c'est maman dans ta
gueule isabelle et zabelle est en forme
en ce moment à 6,6 depuis six ans je
suis le pro de la coordination et de la
synchronisation
on veut faire l'exercice hausse ensemble
non me donner bonne réponse kate ont
découvert hier dans sept à huit
mamie quand tu reviens tu te signal
[Musique]
ans
ces exigences on sera là demain
également avec toi mon chéri de se voir
récompenser toute l'année 2010 devrait
pas récompenser toute l'année 2019